I no longer feel the loneliness I once
felt but instead I am enjoying life and
making the best out of it as a young man
on the verge of finishing high school
high school
[Music]
all right so uh lately we've been kind
of cleaning up the JK office and finding
Hidden Treasures here and there oh wow
this uh kind of came up and it's a big
envelope full of lost JK fan mail from
like years ago
you could send it I think it's still
ours JK films P.O box whatever oh that
PO Box I think it's on the thing does it
still exist PO Box 153 153 is already
paying for it I don't even know so here
I'll let you go through it pick out
something read it all these things are
sealed they've never been opened that's
pretty cool that's pretty messed up
there's a ton dude look you could just
get a handful of things like this wow
and we got a lot and this stuff some of
this stuff is dated like what 2017. bro
this one's
2016. oh geez this one oh it's been open
somebody opened it this one
let's open some of these up if you find
a good one yeah you need to read it out
these open on camera oh oh let's do that
but please don't read the personal part
so when you get to it and you already
read it out loud you're like oh [__]
sorry about that what's the personal
yeah I don't think they'll remember that
I think wow all right this one's hi
there I chanced upon JK news just
sometime last year oh boy am I glad to
have found you guys your YouTube channel
never fails crack me up keep up the good
work just a little something for you
guys if you like them
P.S mad love of GEOS right hand tatt so
this must have not been old if Jill's
right-hand hat is
is pretty fresh
hey if we're reading your letter and
you're somehow still here at the Channel
please comment below more than meets the
eye there is look at their insta this is
what they drew for us dude this one's
crazy I don't know how they they thank
you for drawing a picture of Mike's song
[Laughter]
popular guys
yeah like so he's a great JK member
that's for sure thank you for drawing
Mike's song hi JK fam I have been
watching you Julia cut her hair I've
been watching that's all bro what date
is that she does look better with short
and blue Bart and Gia you remind me of
my sister and her boyfriend they are
always saying things you do
David you were just [__] funny
Joe leader of diwalia you are my fave
you hella funny
wow
but not to read personal Parts hold up
what are the person okay check this out
May 26th
2016 from Sarbor
is that even real okay
they gave me money what the [__] what
the [__] oh wow there's money send it
back dude that's crazy big green things
from whiskey Florida big fan of yours
and your team in one of the videos you
noted like you like collecting banknotes
from all over the world I immigrated
from Tashkent Uzbekistan located in
Central Asia and brought some notes with
me that I don't have a use for who's
Becca whoa so I decided to hit you up
your currency is called Uzbek some the
picture of a museum you see on a
thousand dollar banknote is dedicated to
our ancestor and great conqueror Amir
Timur Tamerlane
please accept this gift to further
expand your collection don't worry it's
not even worth a buck if you convert to
Dollars
are you serious it says that I don't
know it's probably worth something now
dude thank you I'm gonna add it to my
collection that's cool this one's from
Emily Handler
their JK films group Holy balls this
letter may be very long which I
apologize in advance for now so should I
just skip to the end yeah
thank you so [__] much I owe you
everything to you guys again you help me
become me again one day I want to meet
you all and hug you all you're all the
most amazing people except for a few
people that you guys used to have on the
show
crazy they actually wrote that it was
whoa and I'm just kidding I added that
party
oh my God any other photos of my songs
that's the important part all my life I
had really bad anxiety in this year
which was Junior I mean I add it got
worse if you leave anxiety untreated for
too long it can trigger depression which
is what happened to me I was so sick I
lost 45 pounds because I couldn't eat
sounds like a real good thing though I
had to go to the hospital four times for
dehydration I couldn't leave my house
all I did was sleep I was out of school
for six months
six months got real dumb then
approximately I was really depressed I
honestly wanted to die which is horrible
don't do that my dad did that I relied
on YouTube as one of my distractions and
I came across JK films news again I
practically fell in love thank you so
much y'all had me laughing which no one
could really do which I appreciate so so
so so so so much without you guys I
couldn't get through my day still to
this day I have to watch your videos to
fall asleep that means they're boring
out of one of my moods wow wow I hope
she's okay you out there Emily Handler
you good I hope you gave back your 45
pounds if that's what you wanted is
there more crazy this one's just flipped
through it it's crazy that's crazy I got
I got a show like too crazy to read yeah
wow not too crazy to read but it's like
this is this really fan mail watch
flipper on the real reel I got a short
one it's on the opposite look what it's
about that looks like a flyer look what
it's about yeah they want to like read
it out loud
who sent this to us this is not fan mail
this is propaganda [__] dude the way all
right is it from the Dalai Lama no okay
so Kevin Elliott sent this to us and
said why don't minority groups unite to
boycott Hollywood it's super political
series oh [__] probably [__]
overwhelming white dominance in
Hollywood has no place in the 21 21st
century America it's time for a change
and by the way dude we are not
left-handed you need a staple on that
side so
the [__] is this it's opposite bro he's
going for the minority Edge
stressful about this letter even reading
it is that a nice little uh greeting
card yeah this one's tight it says
hey JK family this is all caps hope all
is going well and that this year
continues to bring you many more
blessings in all aspects of your life
thank you for all your hard work on and
off camera to everyone who makes it
possible for us viewers to view the
amazing work being done I always view
all of y'all content and I'm glad
there's some content I can laugh
critically think about and even share to
other friends via YouTube thank you for
all the laughs is there more your fan
Jacqueline B from South Central LA
studying up at NorCal hey nice that's a
really sweet thing I like that you set
the card I don't know why we have so
much there's still more Hey so uh one
thing that like the now era fans wanted
to know if there's a P.O box they can
send stuff to now I think that's it they
wanted to send uh products for product
review they wanted to just buy us [__]
yeah yeah rate this thing yeah but I'm
not gonna eat nothing though oh no I'm
not gonna trust you giving me food you
[__] sabotaging son of a [__] it's a
Ryan thing to do so it's P.O box 153
right it's still the same it should be
when do you guys go to there to pick it
up
we got one from Canada dude oh read it I
actually never go to the
I don't even know where it is there's no
no I pulled them all out here choose
from this bunch
and close my eyes like this one says Joe
and Bart and Bart oh wait a minute you
guys are saying this PO box has been
active the entire time till now probably
I don't know
it's got to be packed then right all
right this one's from Canada and there's
no return because it's a straight murder
uh card dear Barton Joe thank you for
being wonderful role model always watch
your videos from 2010 for seven years so
this must have been uh 2017. dude this
one's from Bank of America you guys have
made my day
congrats on your baby Bart thanks to you
guys Just Kidding Films I always go For
Broke oh that's cute oh and they left
the name from one of your fans Kawaii
wow I got one right here
this is from Jesus Shipley
he says Dear Joe I'm a huge fan of JK
party JK news and your channel and
everything that JK does I like what you
all do this is where it gets a little
interesting
I was hoping that when I turned 18 y'all
could give me a job at the new JK oh too
late dog sorry bud hope you're 18 now
this is like over eight years ago yeah
cause we don't even got that too anymore
he goes so keep doing what y'all do
y'all make me smile what up guys this
episode is brought to you by Lumi and if
you don't know what Lumi is it is a
revolutionary deodorant and you know why
because it's developed by an OB GYN
which is a professional doctor for the
instead of deodorizing it pre-orderizes
because the main ingredient is a
mandelic acid so unlike a lot of
deodorants which just tries to mask your
smells this one uses mandelic acid so it
attacks what's causing the smells before
it happens and you can use it anywhere
because it's pH balance under hoo-ha
under he who on the hee hee and the huhu
which is your penis your vagina your
butthole your your under boob your
thighs anything that's smelly on you put
it anywhere and it smells good for up to
72 hours I'm actually not a very smelly
person but I wanted to try it so I put
it on my beep beep and you know what
when I put on my BB it was perfectly
fine it wasn't like inflamed all of a
sudden because it's ph balanced and you
know what I went like this just to test
because I'm a very experimental guy with
distantly it smells kind of fresh so if
it works on the pp I'm sure it works on
the pupu and if it works on the poopoo
it also wants and the Lumi starter pack
is perfect for new customers it comes
with a solid Stick deodorant a cream
tube deodorant two free products of your
choice like the mini body wash and
deodorant wipes and free shipping as a
special offer for listeners new
customers get five dollars off a Lumi
starter pack with code OTR at lumide.com
that equates to over 40 of your starter
pack when you visit Lumi deodorant.com
and use the code
OTR Premier fan Jesus Shipley PS I hope
you all get this letter thank you Jesus
this was July 13 2016. I mean you
finally got it got it
came in this one's for you baby I wish
this had a date on it oh [__] this one's
from Demetrius Owens it has a little
barbell logo all right like not our
dumbbell logo
Dear Sir or madam
I am writing this letter to thank you
for being such a big part of my life
very professional I have been a fan of
yours for quite a while now and nothing
has changed thank you for the
opportunity of having
a happy and fulfilling life thus far as
I got older I would have troubles with
being happy unless the positive
influences life has to offer is it
cursive no it's just uh like Times New
Roman
through your entertaining videos and
personalities I was able to overcome
this lack of happiness you all have been
a great role model for someone who may
be struggling in life I no longer feel
the loneliness I once felt but instead
I'm enjoying life and making the best
out of it as a young man on the verge of
finishing high school high school the
need to thank the ones who have always
made my life more joyful I ask nothing
in return for just acknowledgment of my
letter would be way more than enough I
thank you again for all the
entertainment you bring and I will
always be a fan Demetrius Owens at first
I thought yeah I'm Demetrius
wow to just kidding film from Rebecca
all the way from England that's cute
what is it called no you broke it wait I
thought that's how you're supposed to do
it
goes this is pool here oh maybe I didn't
do it right she Drew bar she drew me
wait let me see the you what makes me
look like a cat well I don't know maybe
you wore a cat outfit or something you
never wore cat outfits I guess I'm a cat
now that's this is me let me see yours
this one's you
Joe's a human and his you're a cat is he
a doctor in that one
that's funny he's saying what you're I
wonder how many people that were like
Mega fans if they're still around what
they're doing now yeah if they're
watching
um because sometimes in the comments
I'll come across a fad and they're like
yo I've been watching since 2009 or
eight yeah I see a lot of that yeah
it's crazy it would be great if one of
these letters belong to someone who's
still that would have been awesome so
check this out we just got
a sticker from somebody and this is what
it says
supreme leader
okay it goes [__] okay hey JK
oh sorry sir
put that on a water hi JK I'm called
Rebecca I live in England and I am 13
years old
she's the one that Drew barred as a cat
and I damn it I [__] it up she's 13
what is she now like 24 maybe and I've
only recently started
and I've only recently started watching
your videos
um
and uh I'm uh and I'm only 13 here okay
everything is good this one's from
Canada
hey from Prince Edward Island hey JK
crew my name is Samuel Park I've been a
fan for about five years you guys are an
amazing group and I'm sending this from
Prince Edward Island Canada you guys
should come here sometime I just want to
see
um Joe dress up as Dan
what keep it up by the way I'm Korean I
can't wait to cause drama in a friend
group is what they said dude I really
like the idea of someone taking the time
to physically right now it is very sweet
I totally forgot what that's like a lost
art yeah and some of them use cursive
some of the handwriting is very good
this I by this handwriting I know this
is a Korean guy
oh really why because there is a rage
yeah yeah neat handwriting very gel
Penny we're gonna open up the one from
Bank of America now see Bank of America
was you know they like to talk you were
past due they like to under penalties of
perjury I declare that I have examined
the information of this form this is not
very nice
I don't like Bank of America make
America is killing the vibe this one is
from 2016.
2016. hi my name is Cindy Nguyen I'm
writing to you because it's something we
are doing in class I'm Vietnamese I'm
only doing this and I am 15 years old
I live in I live with my mom's stepdad
and little brother both me and my
brother enjoy watching y'all's videos a
lot y'all inspire me a lot in ways that
are hard to explain I want to do YouTube
but I'm very shy if it's okay I would
love an autograph of everyone from Just
Kidding Films and an autographed picture
of Gina for my friend he loves her
my address is my Florida
I wanted to say thank you so much I love
the spirit y'all have that's a lot of
y'alls huh yeah what's up y'all it's
very inspiring because I'm shy and quiet
I've broken out of my shell a lot more
I've been watching your videos for a
while I especially love the videos you
did of you know your Asian win thank you
you know what's cool like if some of
these people are still watching they're
basically hearing you read them out loud
as children like they were kids I know
this is all 2016. we're basically
embarrassing them right now so if you
wrote and we read your email or your
email your letter like comment below
dude yeah tell us who you are it would
be so embarrassed if someone read my fan
mail from like when I wrote when I was
like 14. it's like a time count it's a
time capsule yeah it really is we got
one um from Fang Chia Lee from St Paul
Minnesota wow I don't know yeah I don't
know I gotta open it though dang you
guys have fans worldwide baby oh [__] I
got another written one this one's um
Kevin Vu dear just kidding film Just
Kidding Films one of the few channels on
YouTube that many of us viewers tune
into for a little laughter in the day a
channel that is growing steadily as the
years progress you most likely want to
keep on showing your viewers what more
you have to offer as the years continue
between the years of 2013 to 2016 I have
been a subscriber to both JK films and
jknews along with their personal
channels also after spending close to
four years watching you guys I feel that
having more of your amazing and
hilarious skits is necessary for thank
you for the Improvement letter to
improve more from just the beginning
with only just the two uncles Uncle Chen
and Uncle Sam up until today with the
entire JK crew I am sure that the
excitement and passion of making the
fabulous short skits that your fans
eagerly wait to watch still burn deeply
as is waiting to come out with hundreds
of prank and react channels everywhere
people are getting sick of the same old
material but with you guys going along
with their motto teaching good things in
a bad way you're always trying to find a
new and creative ways to teach a lesson
even if it is in a bad way as YouTube
starts to grow bigger and bigger more
content is is needed to entertain the
viewers such as skitas friends friend
zone bad grades and Gung Fu show that
the teaching the struggles with everyday
life can actually be hilarious and not
serious because of the incredible fan
base that was gathered because of your
skits dating that's too many because
it's dude from all the way back was day
one it is clear that you should start
doing more of them I believe that
squeezing in one skit every couple of
weeks is a reasonable offer thank you
Dad from your busy days of taking care
of kids watching anime dodging metal
pipes eating pizza video running the
country of jamali or even dealing with a
crazy parent who you just can't help but
love
thank you for all the Improvement but
the algorithm told us not to do skitzim
okay
15 right yeah
once a week come on just do one were you
stupid yeah it's not that hard he's
bargaining with you Kevin Vu from
Pennsylvania reasonable Kevin Boom man
thank you guys thank you guys this is
pretty cool this is pretty fun that none
of these things have ever been opened
time capsules dude so hopefully when you
guys go to that PO box wherever it is we
can get the rest of the letters out of
there we should we
have another 10 years from now
[Music]